[Musique]
Bernard tapis un homme à 1000 vies 1000
métiers chanteur
acteur PDG pilote automobile
navigateur pourquoi cette boulimie vous
aviez quelque chose à vous prouver à
vous-même ça me fait plaisir cette
question parce que ma
réponse vous pourrez la vérifier ouais
et je reconnais assez
inédite je n'ai jamais de toute ma vie
et pour tous les métiers que ce soit
ministre patron de l'OM patron d'Adidas
ou acteur je n'ai jamais dit tiens
j'aimerais faire
ça jamais ah bon aucun projet n'a été
fait sans que ce soit une proposition
alors Bernard tapis c'est quoi c'est le
c'est l'appétit du pouvoir je l'ai pas
compris c'est pas le problème puisque
c'est pas moi qui prenais l'initiative
de tenter vous donnez-moi un exemple
vous alors donnez-moi un exemple vous
vouliez absolument quand vous avez eu
l'OM être champion d'Europe oui mais
c'est pas moi qui je acheter l'OM est-ce
que vous aviez une revanche à prendre
sur je sais vle Mamer mais c'est pas le
cas pas pas du
toutz milieu ass modeste mais c'est pas
pour autant que ça m'a donné envie autre
chose vos parents vous avez beaucoup
d'admiration pour vos parents beaucoup
mon père a été ouvrier fraer non il
était ajusteurjusteur et après il est
devenu frigoriste ou mon père c'est un
des hommes les plus intelligents que
j'ai rencontré et pourtant j'en ai
rencontré beaucoup il était le seul à
pas le savoir et comme il était fils de
chemin il a fait son CAP d'ajusteur et
puis s'est arrêé là et bien que
communiste la lutte des class c'était
pas son truc il a fallu que je lui
prouve petit à petit qu'il méritait
beaucoup mieux car de lui-même il en
était ni conscient ni volontaire et il
est devenu chef d'entreprise à 55 ans
grâce à vous bah évidemment c'est pas le
père qui a fait le fils c'est les deux
fils qu'on fait le père mon frère et moi
mais la vie pour vous c'est quand même
un match il faut qu'il ait un adversaire
il faut que vous il faut que vous
battiez mais c'est inro incroyable cette
idée que vous avez de moi non c'est rien
à voir je mets de mon côté tous les
atouts pour que quand on me confie une
mission je la réussisse évidemment mais
je suis pas en train de dire faut sois
le premier ça c'est une vision de ce de
ceux qui font rien parce que si vous
aviez cette vision en tendant des choses
je vais vous poser une question vous
êtes arriz au niveau où vous êtes en
tant que journaliste en vous disant
fautar faut sois le meilleur parce que
j'avais aussi de la volonté mais vous
vous avez la volonté vous avez une
volonté de faire c'est pas par la c'est
pas pour alors c'est quoi le ressort
mais attendez la volonté c'est autre
chose c'est pas ça que vous décrivez
vous décriviez l'espèce d'envie d'être
quelqu'un ou à tout prix pas du tout
mais vous étiez content de gagner quand
même quand vous avez gagné rien à voir
c'est la logique dujet vous savez ce
qu'on se dit on se dit que Bernard Rino
en 1984 quand il gagne le Tour de France
avec La Vie Claire sous votre sponsor
l'OM en en 1993 quand il gagne la Coupe
d'Europe on se dit mais Bernard tapis il
était sur le vélo et il était sur le
stade c'est quoi la recette de la gagne
la recette de la gagne c'est d'abord
d'essayer de t'entourer de tous les gens
qui savent des choses que vous ne savez
pas vous numéro 1 numéro 2 je vais vous
donner un exemple quand je fais l'OM
ou quand monsieur deniso fait le PSG h
il fait une équipe homogène avec des
gens complémentaires qui chacun a son
poste a fait la démonstration de sa
force et a fait du football à sport
d'équipe quand le catarien fait le PSG
il fait de ce sport un sport individuel
qui se joue à plusieurs moralité
évidemment par rapport à la France il a
gagné par rapport à l'Europe c'est plus
dur voyez qu'il faut être absolument
intransigent sur les règles établies pas
par vous établies par le milieu donc
quand on gagne on gagne parce qu'on est
une bonne équipe toujours quel que soit
le SO secteur dans lequel nous sommes et
surtout quand je reprends Adidas je
pique le patron du marketing de chez
Nike hm hm je prends le ministre des
Finances allemand je mets président hm
hm on élargit le club des sponsors au
Bayern et à stéphigraf on fait le Real
Madrid et cetera il y a pas de recette
il faut pas à la limite à ma place où
j'étais savoir grand-chose mais
simplement savoir tout ce que vous ne
savez pas mais vous avez après ou après
j'ai un don c'est de savoir dire aux
gens quand tu crois que tu es au bout tu
as fait à peine la moitié h alors si
c'est un sportif il sort il me dit oh je
suis vidé ah bon mais il m'a semblé que
tu sortais du terrain debout tu as vu
les skurs de fond quand ils arrivent sur
la ligne autrement dit c'est de leur
dire quand tu crois que tu as été au
bout tu as pas fait la moitié encore
autrement dit donnez envie de tout
donner voilà alors après c'est vrai
qu'il y a la volonté 1 c'est je voudrais
bien ouais 2 c'est je veux 3 c'est je
veux
absolument et c'est celui-là qui réussit
c'est absolument c'est le absolument
mais c'est pas au détriment ou par des
méthodes c'est simplement je le veux
vraiment est-ce que Dieu vous vous aide
est-ce que vous êtes croyant d'ailleurs
oui est-ce que ça vous aide quand alors
pas làaires dans le SP pas là-dedans
parce que je crois j'ai d'ailleurs dit
récemment à quelqu'un quand à fois de
baleur rentre sur le terrain qui fait ça
qui bon c'est bien mais c'est c'est pas
possible hein Dieu existe pas pour ça
pas pour gagner un match de football et
donc je le réserve pour tout à fait
autre chose il existe pourquoi Dieu
alors il existe pour vous donner un sens
à votre vie est-ce que vous avez fait
plus de mal que de bien est-ce que quand
vous avez fait le mal vous avez aussi
essayé de compenser les écoles de
formation c'est parce que ben c'est
parce que je faisais des licenciements
je pouvais pas rester là-dessus et vous
avez fait plus de mal que de bien non
j'ai fait plus de bien que de mal par
exemple j'ai appris à ne pas être encugé
h et tous les gens qui m'ont fait du mal
sauf si c'est des amis c'estàd des gens
qui me touchent là vous coupz à ce
moment-là hein à ce moment-là vous
coupez si c'est des gens mais je souffre
je veux plus le voir ouais je veux plus
le voir parce qu'il me fait du mal c'est
arrivé ouai c'est arrivé mais pas
souvent mais on a l'impression que vous
êtes un homme seul vous êtes pas un
homme de clan vous nêtes pas unom homme
de réseau vous n'avez pas fréquenté la
franc-maçonnerie ah ouais et et que vous
êtes c'est vous qui décidez il y a une
demi heure avant que vous m'appeliez là
que vous venz me chercher ouais j'étais
avec Noël Bellon qui était secrétaire
général du groupe Bernard tapis pendant
20 ans non non on est comme ça tous tous
les anciens de basilboli en passant par
ceux qui étaient à mon ministère et
basilboli vous appelle régulièrement
tous on s'appelle et quand vous avez des
problèmes il vous appelle aussi oui
alors uniquement pour vous demander des
conseils non mais il m'envoie des petits
mots ouais pour me dirait tiens bon et
dans le monde des affaires parce que
comme vous avez eu une pare une une vie
extrêmement rich vous avez dirigé des
beaucoup d'entreprises vender bu je suis
resté ami avec les vrais les grands
grand c'est qui est vrai Pinot François
Pinot oui qui est un grand pourquoi
c'est un grand ah ben c'est un grand
parce qu'il a démarré avec pas
grandchose vous aimez c'est les gens qui
démarrent à non parce que si tu démarres
là et que tu vas là Arnaud il a pas
démarré là mais c'est fabuleux ce qu'il
a fait extraordinaire donc vous pouvez
très bien avoir fait Polytechnique et
être génial mais vous pouvez aussi avoir
eu votre CP d'électricien et être génial
hein le tout c'est pas ça et ceuxlà
comme par hasard c'est des gens avec qui
j'ai toujours eu de très bons contacts
Xavier Niel pour moi est un modèle qui
prend ma suite si je dire c'est le
Bernard tapide
aujourd'huiavierel par beaucoup de
points de vue mais en plus doué je crois
qu'il est plus doué que moi encore il
arrive à faire quelque chose qui
aujourd'hui est une denrée presque
impossible qui était pas le cas à mon
époque vous avez connu on était plus
généreux on était plus copinard on était
plus avec les autres cette société a
rendu les gens plus égoïstes aujourd'hui
plus personnel et c'est pas son cas et
en politique vous avez eu des amis oui
Nicolas Sarkozi c'est un ami pour vous
je peux pas dire ça parce que il était
président de la République donc on a des
relations qui sont celles que j'avais à
l'époque où il était président et vous
faisait partie de ceux qui de temps en
temps me disait qu'est-ce que tu ferais
dans ce cas-là et Jean-Louis borlot
c'est un ami aussi oui il est rest un
ami oui et il y a des
ennemis en politique oui mais les
ennemis politique je les comprends par
exemple François Hollande oui qui a
relancé l'affaire Adidas il a pas
relancé il l'a créé oui non mais quand
après il a voulu casser l'arbitrage
repartir devant la
justice et avec des procès en pagaille
euh il voulait prendre une revanche sur
vous
logique pouroi logique logique sa femme
se présente j'étais plutôt de gauche
vraiment sa femme se présente je l'ai
côtoyé je sais ce qu'elle vaut elle a
plein de qualité j'ai fait les marchés
avec elle pour l'aider à être député
mais président de la République faut pas
rêver donc c'est royale face à Nicolas
que je connaissais pas et qui m'avait
chié dans les
en 95 vous voyez que j'ai plus de
rancune du tout quand il s'agit de
favoriser pour la France quelqu'un
contre quelqu'un d'autre h donc eux qu
essaie de me tuer après c'est normal
c'est normal que Holland tué j'ai je les
ai empêché de gagner j'ai fait tout pour
pas qu'il gagne Holland a gagné quand
même pas sa femme et Christine Lagarde
par exemple qui a été
très déçu d'elle Adidas je suis très
déçu qui a passé devant la Cour de
Justice de la répuqueelle pas elle a pas
dit un mot et elle a pas été condamnée à
une peine on a dit qu'elle avait été
négligente elle vous a déçu
elle m'a déçu de pas s'être défendu
quand j'ai demandé qu'elle vienne
témoigner un autre procès oui elle a pas
voulu donc elle a manqué de courage ah
non mais je dis pas ça a dit que vous
seriez pas son ami en tous les cas oui
ben ça c'est logique elle non plus elle
elle non plus quoi parce que c'est une
différence de milieu de culture de bah
on n pas d'Atom COCHU h mais c'est une
grande dame il y a pas de doute et alors
les journalistes parce que donc
l'affaire Adidas qui fait couler
beaucoup d'ancre depuis maintenant 25
ans et qui est pas terminé euh les
journalistes la presse a eu en majorité
la dent très dure pour vous en disant
que toute manière c'était tout ça
c'était vous le méritiez en
gros le renvoulez au journaliste à
l'agent de journalistique non je m'en
fous complètement m'en fous foutz des
médias et puis al attend complètement
mais ça les médias pourtant ve dire quoi
c'est moi qui vous ai appelé non c'est
moi alors arrêtez ça non non mais
attendez arrêtez ça tous vous êtes
pareil vous passez des heures à vouloir
m'inviter et quand vous m'invitez tous
alors vous aimez vous montrer non non
mais vous aimez vous aimez je n'aime pas
ça pas les médias mais c'est pas le
sujet mais est-ce que vous êtes pas
meurtri parce que vous lisez parfois ce
que vous entendez ce qui vous concerne
parce que je m'en fous ma vie elle est
faite de choses qui satisfont ou pas
ceux qui m'intéressent et ce pour qui
j'existe votre opinion sur moi je
m'assoie dessus donc je m'en fous ça
peut être un moteur aussende d'autre
part vous donnez pas et vous prêtez pas
le pouvoir que vous n'avez pas vous
faites l'humeur pas l'opinion h la
preuve c'est que dans les médias je vais
prendre justement un fait ouais la
justice il y a deux types de
journalistes il y a le mec qu'on appelle
d'investigation qui fut rien qui est
juste à la solde d'un procureur d'un
juge ou je ne sais qui c'est dire qu'il
investigue pas mais il reçit information
on lui file les machins et vous avez les
chroniqueurs de justice qui vont au
procès qui s'y connaissent enendroit
ceux-là qui étaient venus au procès vous
avez été relaxé ils ont pas attendu la
relaxe he oui oui pour dire mais
qu'est-ce que c'est que ce merdier parce
que d'un seul coup c'était pas que les
suites organisé par le CDR c'était les
plaignants et les
réponses et les journalistes ont
félicité la présidente qui a rendu le
jugement qu' a rendu mais il a fallu du
temps pour quand même pour que la presse
et ben ilelle a fallu procès et
rappelez-vous donnez-moi au moins acte
je n'ai jamais voulu alimenter la
controverse dès qu'on me parlait du
procès je disais je veux pas vous en
parler venez à l'audience et vous vous
êtes patron de presse maintenant vous
avez un journal qui s'appelle la
province ça vous amuse et je n'y mets
pas mon petit doigt alors il y a un
grand homme est-ce que c'est celui que
vous avez le plus admiré de tous ceux
que vous avez rencontré c'est François
mitan ah c'est l'homme qui m'a le plus
impressionné pourquoi parce que quand on
le connaissait en vrai il avait une
faculté incroyable c'est d'avir une
analyse et une capacité intellectuelle
qui se mettait à votre diapason à votre
niveau et un pouvoir de conviction
inimaginable il avait en plus ce qu'on
appelle la force de l'esprit il l'avait
vraiment il est é sincère et alors vous
êtes venu avec lui bon vous avez
d'ailleurs vous avez vous aviez des
convictions politiques très arrêtées
parce que quand on lit sur vous on dit
qu'à un moment vous pensiez faire un
bout de chemin avec le
RPR et puis que finalement bon
c'estouche c'est à gauche que vous êtes
allé Jama non à gauche que vous êtes
allé et en 1992 c'est le radicau de
gauche radicau de gauche en 1992
bergovois devient premier ministre tapis
devient ministre de la vie
de figures atypiques finalement à
l'époque de seuls fils d'ouvrier voilà
sur tout le gouvernement de gauche on
deux fils de prolo et ça ça vous a
attiré finalement la jalousie des autres
non des autres socialistes qui eux
sortai de normals pas tous
du
j même Fabius c'était pas mes ennemis
alors mitan quand même vous l'avez
admiré ou il vous a pas un peu
instrumentalisé quand même ou ou il a
plutôt causé c'est à partir avec lui que
vous avez commencé à avoir vos ennuis
finalement oui parce que il vous demande
il m'a demandé des conseils il vous
demande de quitter la présidence
d'Adidas oui pour devenir ministre il
m'a demandé des conseils c'est-à-dire B
il m'a demandé des
choses des conseil bah je vais pas vous
le dire ça je suis pas le genre mais ça
arrive à des présidents d'avoir des gens
qui s'interrogent pourquoi moi je vais
vous dire quelque chose Monsieur quand
je dis au
cancéreux dans mes premiers interview de
cancéreux alors qu'il y a pas le covid
et que je dis chers amis on est dans le
même bateau j'ai un conseil à vous
donner serrez les dents battez-vous il y
a rien de foutu parce que les progrès
vont tellement vite que notre
condamnation à mort d'aujourd'hui elle
est pas forcément vraie demain quand je
dis ça et je leur dit de se remet le cul
imaginez que j'ai pas le cancer
moi-même qu'est-ce qu'ils auraient dit
les cancéreux ça te va bien connard
c'est facile à dire quand je dis moi au
fils d'en bas battez-vous il y a rien de
foutu que je fais
ambition et quand je fais ambition c'est
mystérant qui demande à
TF1 de faire ambition avec moi
parce qu'il m'a vu dans une émission qui
s'appelait vive la crise ouis et il
m'appelle il dit Monsieur parle au
français de l'entreprise et du rôle que
ceux qui viennent d'en bas peuvent jouer
et il demande à TF1 de faire ambition et
je fais ambition on fait 14 15 millions
si je venais pas d'où je viens comment
je peux faire ambition mais avec c'est à
partir du moment je ne dis pas qu'il est
la cause et que c'est lui mais vous
quittez Adidas et donc vous vendez
Adidas et là on rentre dans une affaire
qui est toujours en
cours Vous vous attirez la haine de
certains socialistes à gauche et c'est
là que ça commence à déraper oui alors
j'aurais j'aurais dû faire quoi pas le
faire je sais pas est-ce que vous le
regrettez ça non mais bien sûr que non
d'avoir la politique ça ça vous a pas
brûlé ah ça m'a peut-être indiqué encore
plus ce que je pensais dans la société
il y a tous ceux qui sont là très
nombreux qui sont d'abord pas jaloux h
sa quand ils vont à saintropé ils se
mettent derrière le cul des bateaux et
ils se font photographier h h et puis il
y a ceux qui ont réussi h et ceux-là ils
sont pas jaloux et ils m'envolent pas
d'avoir réussi à ma manière ils sont
là-haut et puis il y a ceux qui sont là
qui voudrai bien et qui peuvent pas et
qui déteste et cela et ceela ouais mais
encore plus ceux de là qu'on réussit
parce que la vie est pas juste parce que
vous rendez compte quand tu fais les et
que tu es pas milliardaire ou que tu as
pas vraiment le pouvoir alors la vie est
mal faite donc badabou
quand par contre ceux-l ont des
responsabilités comme à Bery par exemple
alors là quand vous tombez entreur
paluche parce que il y a l'énarc qui a
réussi à être un grand banquier ou à
être ministre ou être président de la
République mais il y a celui qui est
voilà parce que faut pour être au
plafond faut pas être seulement ancien
élève de l'énat faut aussi avoir un peu
le cerveu droit et vous vous a été au
plafond ah ouais et moi alors là cela
vous imaginez
pas parce qu'en plus il fréquente la
gloire le pouvoir le blé et en fait ils
ont rien de tout ça et vous vous avez
tout mais noni j'ai rien de tout ça non
plus puisque je suis ruiné j'ai pas de
pouvoir et j'ai la gloire vous avez la
gloire vous aimez ça oh vous pouvez pas
savoir c'est pour ça que j'ai fait votre
émission pour être vu par des millions
de gens on va être vu au moins par 10000
alors euh Bernard tap Bernard tapis non
Bernard tapis il y a pas très longtemps
vous avez présidé un jury de concours
d'éloquence
ouais et le thème de ce jury c'était
réussir dans la vie les apprentis
avocats ou les avocats ont fait leur
leur pldoirie
et vous les avez repris au vol tous
parce que vous avez fait une distinction
disant il y a réussir dans la vie et
réussir sa vie est-ce que vous vous avez
réussi dans la
vie ou votre vie ou les deux j'ai réussi
ma vie d'accord réussir sa vie alors
j'ai fait une chanson et ça commence
comme ça réussir sa vie c'est prendre la
main d'un enfant le cœur d'une femme qui
vous
sourit le soir je sais plus comment
c'est après attends c'est prendre la
main dans l'enfant le cœur d'une femme
qui vous sourit et là
cette femme c'est Dominique ouais pour
vous elle est là vous êtes tous les deux
elle est quand même belle très belle
femme 45 ans très belle femme toujours à
vos côtés ouais et moi
aussi un couple fusionnel
ouis elle vous a toujours tenu dans les
moments les plus difficiles elle vous a
est-ce qu'elle vous a dissuadé de vous
engager dans certaines cause dans C
jamais y compris sur la politique parce
que si l'avait fait oui je n'y serais
pas allé il faut que vous sachiez que
c'est ma première et souvent unique
conseillère ou mais
vraiment par conséquent elle a son
domaine de compétence bien sûr mais la
son
analyse un jour pour vous dire à quel
point elle a du nez elle a fait une
interview télé dans toute sa vie avec
Drucker il y a 40 ans et trier lui dit
alors tout se passe bien c'est
formidable on habitait rue des
saint-pèes un endroit où j'avais aucune
chance d'accéder et j'avais dit à
l'époque sauf en étant facteur du
7e et elle elle
dit
rappelez-vous si jamais un jour il pose
un genou par terre ça va être la
curée voilà ce que ma femme a dit un
jour à la télé à drugè tellement elle
était lucide sur le fait qu'on attendait
qu'une chose c'était ça parce que vous
étiez la belle gueule le parce que
j'étais là où je devais pas être voilà
et vous génez finalement et j'avais un
tort que j'ai négligé c'est que dans
tous les milieux où tu
arrive fais-toi tente de te faire
accepter
aujourd'hui vous avez c'est un secret
pour personne vous avez des cancers vous
êtes atteint de plusieurs cancers vous
luttez est-ce que vous trouvez que le
regard des gens sur vous a a changé
justement grâce ou à cause de ça je sais
pas comment il faut le dire non il y a
eu deux événements à mon avis premier
événement
c'est ils ont pris
conscience que j'étais
toujours destiné à aller au service des
autres il a cette facette de moi qui
était pas connu deuxièmement quand un
procureur de la République a culot après
la démonstration
implacable que j'étais totalement
innocent de ce dont on m'accuse depuis
20 ans et que les journalistes en
étaient les témoins il demandent le
procureur
avferme vos collègues d'un seul coup ils
ont dit c'est pas possible et donc ils
ont
changé ils ont commencé à
raconter ce que ils avaient dit à tort
et moi quand la quand la juge m'a dit
Monsieur tapis est-ce que vous avez une
déclaration à faire je me suis un peu
avancé il s'est demandé ce qu' allit se
passé Monsieur le Procureur cureur je
vous remercie vous êtes plus optimiste
que mes médecins
et là la salle a compris tout ce que ça
pouvait ressentir de demander 5 ans
ferme voilà c'est la gagne encore là
quand même he ouais vous êtes un gagneur
bah je suis pas un perd vous voulez
gagner tout non je veux pas perdre
arrêtez je veux pas perdre vous êtes
revanchard quand même aussi oui là oui
là oui parce que d'accord le cancer
l'ésophage et de l'estomac c'est un
cancer qui arrive quand on se fait du
mauvais sang et c'est un cancer adidass
ah bah c'est un cancer créditlionnais
créitlionnais une chose que vous
regrettez non non non non vous prenez
tout ouais vous retenez tout non je
retiens pas justement c'est vive demain
vive demain voilà j'ai lu vous aviez des
projets ah énorme des projets théâtre
oui ça oui mais ça va revenir théâtre et
puis enfin beaucoup dans le spectacle
quand même hein non on va inventer avec
la région PACA ouais une séquence de
temps que je trouve mal utilisée pour
l'instant la vie c'est trois périodes
oui c'est tu nais tu travailles première
période école machin tu travailles tu es
à la retraite deuxème période 3ème
période tu es à la retraite tu crèves il
en manque une laquelle c'est celle entre
tu travailles et tu travailles plus
ouais parce que entre j'ai arrêté de
travailler à faire ce que mon boulot m'a
fait faire il y a une séquence c'est
celle qui va te faire faire ce que tu as
toujours rêvé de faire et que tu as
jamais fait de la musique de la peinture
du sport la chanson de l'agriculture
biologique ma femme fait de la danse a
70 ans elle fait TR fois par semaine de
la danse avec des gens tous les âges et
vous et moi non j'ai tout fait ce que
j'aimais vous avez encore des choses que
vous pouvez faire non faire faire aux
autres ce que moi j'ai fait donner aux
autres voil la générosité voilà merci
Bernard tap merci
Monsieur
[Musique]